como una trama de espionaje así se vivió
el más reciente intercambio de
prisioneros entre Estados Unidos y Moscú
la estadounidense Britney y el ruso
Víctor Wood fueron los protagonistas la
operación de entrega Debut llevada a
cabo en una pista de emiratos árabes fue
rápida y bien coordinada Boot incluso
ofreció declaraciones a la prensa
nacional al llegar a territorio ruso
en medio de la noche simplemente me
despertaron y me dijeron junta tus cosas
y eso fue todo no hubo información
preliminar ni siquiera sabías a dónde te
llevaban no te dijeron nada estaba Claro
que la situación se estaba desarrollando
de esta manera Víctor Wood es un
Traficante de armas conocido como el
mercader de la muerte Incluso se le
atribuyen algunos hechos reflejados en
la película estadounidense el señor de
la guerra de Nicolas Cage fue uno de los
hombres más buscados del mundo su
negocio lo hizo dominar varios idiomas
entre ellos el persa inglés y francés la
consolidación su carrera como traficante
se dio después de la caída de la unión
soviética aprovechando el excedente de
armas producto de la desintegración se
espera que Estados Unidos y Rusia den un
paso más y vuelvan a la mesa de
negociaciones para liberar al Marín Paul
William detenido en territorio
euroasiático desde 2018